[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance and kissin
and this is to show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people our brilliant guests this week is
one of the world's most renowned
relationship experts he wrote a book a
very long time ago in many sins
called men are from Mars Women are from
Venus a book that I mind my wife
personally found very useful dr. John
grey welcome to trigonometry
oh really happy to be with you thank you
so much for coming on the show there's
really a couple of things we wanted to
talk about later in in the interview we
want to get on to you know this time of
lockdown with the coronavirus how do you
maintain your relationship how do you
not get divorced in this time and
whatever else your personal goals might
be well yeah you know in China when
people are released their the divorce
rate has dramatically gone up because
people are confined together we we need
our own independence as well as
connection as important as Connection is
we need separation and with no
separation it brings up all kinds of
issues that are actually will be
remedied if we understand the dynamics
of how to live in a space and create
distance without fights the arguments
serve a purpose I want to push you away
for a while so I can come back to myself
there's other ways to do it without the
arguments because that then builds
mistrust and that leads to divorce and
lack of appreciation so we're gonna get
into that today yeah we'd love to get
into that towards the second half of the
interview but the first thing you know
we're called trigonometry because we
like to explore controversial and
difficult ideas what one of the things
that you didn't need perhaps to cover in
your first book in 1992 when you talked
about the differences between men and
women it was probably widely accepted at
the time that they exist and one of the
things that seems to have happened since
is with the you know the culture war and
everything else that in itself has
become a controversial issue and your
latest books talk very much about the
hormonal differences between men and
women the brain differences between men
and we
so why is it important to recognize
those differences and how do you use
those to create more harmonious
relationships well that was a nice
review of the last 30 years I summed it
up into one sentence yeah save me time
there you know when I started I started
talking about gender differences in 1982
okay
and back then it was more controversial
and you know you say people understood
the differences but what we had was in
1982 we had the whole 80s I'm sorry the
whole 70s and 60s to build up this body
of knowledge that was starting to say
that something's wrong with men they
should be more like women and women
should be more like men and that was
what my call radical feminism you know
where I'm a feminist in terms of not
radical I'm for equality I'm for
supporting women tremendously women have
been majorly supportive of my book and
ironically when men came out men started
reading this book well my publishers
told me it's like a phenomena men buy
your book just as much as women because
it supports you know man and being okay
with themselves women learning to
understand men so suddenly men to note
these bad guys but when you don't know
how to support a man or correctly
interpret a man then what happens is you
feel unloved you feel hurt you know the
big theme of metaphor Mars was we men go
to our man cave you know that became a
national phenomena for a minute from
Mars is all men have a man cave and that
changed relationships dramatically prior
to that after feminism it was like if a
man's not like a woman wanting to
connect all the time share and open his
feelings and so forth then something's
wrong with him now he's dysfunctional so
certainly this interesting thing
certainly there's some men just this or
some women who are dysfunctional I mean
the world is filled with great people
and dysfunctional people but when men
need their cave time it's not
dysfunctional it's just that when women
grew up with a father who was
dysfunctional not available
they were so hurt by that by his
mistreatment as opposed to him needing
save time save time which is many to
pull away so really in the beginning I
had women who would get mad at me and
yell and scream at me and interrupt my
seminars with screams some men would get
how dare you say this you know I should
be more I'm not going to be like my
father and take my cape I'm I should
always be there for women so was it just
women but also men and that's what drove
me to find a metaphor a minute from mars
women are from venus because when you
use that metaphor there's kind of a
chuckle yeah where's my husband from and
i remember when i came up with that it
was two years of teaching gender
differences when i realized we had got
off track the universities were teaching
psychology and there's so many good
ideas in psychology but then it got
twisted and it got twisted there's
something wrong with men we need to
change men and we don't understand men
but we think we know what they should be
and men basically don't understand women
we never really really have pride in
that we do you know always in the old
days make oh I don't understand my wife
but I love her okay but what I was able
to do with men from Mars its help men to
understand women better it is not about
becoming denying who women are it's
understanding them better so I can
understand how to provide even more
support for women because men will give
their life for women you know that's
what we do we're the soldiers we're the
gun with the fire men we're the guys
that go out and do the dirty difficult
dangerous jobs that's what men are about
but the problem is when men don't feel
appreciated when there's no parades for
the soldiers you know when there's no
reward clapping for them for the health
care workers right now in my town every
night and eight o'clock all the dogs are
barking because all the people are
playing loud music and they're cheering
and they're making noises it's
appreciating those health care workers
we need to be fed if you're out there
taking risks and doing dangerous things
but when men don't feel needed they go
down and that's what's happening today
is more dysfunctional men primarily just
because we're not bringing out the best
in them by loving them
and appreciating them and see the good
in them so we've kind of lost that so
when I came out with minute for Mars I
had to find a playful way to do it
people always say you know how did you
come up with that idea a necessity
I prayed I'm a very spiritual person as
well every day helped me find a way to
present this idea without people taking
it personally without people getting all
mad about it like I'm a sexist or
something and so I was teaching a
seminar back in 1983 and and and I just
seen a teen you know et Extra
Terrestrial was that everybody's mind at
that time a huge hit movie and I was a
bunch of women in audience some men and
I I said women you have to imagine your
husband's et and I was saying that
because I wanted them to recognize maybe
it's okay for him to eat Reese's
chocolates because he's from another
planet that was the idea is that et
would eat Reese's chocolates and that's
what he needed whereas everybody thinks
oh that's bad for you that's bad for you
don't give it to him so I was going to
make that point I never did because as
soon as I said women imagine your
husband's et they all broke into
laughter and then some woman I think she
was drunk she goes where's my where's my
husband from that I said Mars and they
laughed they loved it I went thank you
god the hairs on my arms stood up stood
up I said this is it this is the answer
be playful about it that's one of the
key things you know when people fall in
love they're playful then we get too
serious and one of the reasons we get
too serious is that our basic needs
stop getting met in the beginning we
anticipate our basic needs being met we
don't have to articulate them we may
know them you know when you you know
part of being a health expert as well is
we have all these needs for vitamins and
nutrients most people don't know what
they need you could have scurvy because
you're not getting a vitamin C and you
don't know you know why do i scurvy what
my point is when people are unhappy in
relationships they really don't know
what they need but they think they do
you know if you've got scurvy you think
all I need any bunch of sugar that's
what I need cuz sure
feels so good I need more ice cream but
if you don't get your vitamin C you'll
get a health problem so what I see today
is people don't know what they need and
so they're looking for the wrong things
and why don't we know what we need
culture used to teach us but culture can
no longer provide what we need or teach
us what do we need and how to get it you
can't get something else you know you
need it because the world has changed so
much our needs have changed that's the
whole key of my message now beyond Mars
and Venus and that's how it's changed
with all this gender neutrality we have
a greater need to understand our gender
differences so that we can give
ourselves what we need and so we give
our partners what they need in order to
find the balance of the masculine and
feminine inside of us and John so we
were talking about where we touched on
the subject of hormones very very
briefly and you were talking about what
happens when a men go down now I've
heard many of your podcast and I've read
a few of your books and will you touch
them with hormones is fascinating not in
particular what happens to the male body
when he gets the breast they start to
produce East Room which it then starts
to produce aggressive behavior could you
go into that a little bit for us please
yes yeah I love that that's one of my
favorite points in beyond Mars Venus
because most people think testosterone
the male hormone and then have a lot
more of it causes aggression
dysfunctional behavior actually it's the
female hormone estrogen any man who's
aggressive has high estrogen at that
moment and his testosterone levels are
going down and this is the opposite of
what most people think it was Stanford
University around 2000 year 2000 they
discovered this but it's still not
common knowledge we still think oh
masculinity causes dysfunction actually
it's when men are not feeling masculine
they're more feminized that they either
have this their testosterone goes down
their estrogen goes up and when that
happens they these are some of the
symptoms of it aggression is one symptom
if we witness aggression as a child a
lot of this is conditioning in the brain
when we go out of balance we go into
fight or flight if I'm a child and I saw
aggression
it goes into my computer side of my
brain then when I'm in fight-or-flight
I'll go into aggression if my dad was
basically more passive and with salt and
pull away than all salt and pull away
but these are all imbalances caused by
going into fight or flight and that's a
hormonal expression of cortisol at that
time and for men their estrogen is going
up at that time for women their
testosterone is going up so let's look
at the foundation and we can have fun
with this which is men basically need 10
to 30 times more testosterone than a
woman to feel loved ok that's to feel
good to feel a fulfilled to be fill your
life has meaning your testosterone has
to be up now your life has to have
meaning for your life for your
testosterone to go up but we have this
biological difference when I solve your
problem when I do something get paid for
it when I do something that people
applauded when I do something and I say
someone's life that's a meaning on my
masculine side my testosterone will go
up I made a difference ok I made a
difference if a woman is making a
difference in her body she makes
testosterone as well and testosterone
feels good to both men and women but it
doesn't lower stress for women what
lowers stress for women is estrogen or
progesterone these are these two female
hormones and what helps her find that
balance is another hormone called
oxytocin we'll talk more about those
hormones but these will just say for now
feminine hormones masculine hormone and
when we have well-being those hormones
are in balance but when women today are
doing traditional male jobs and I'm not
against that in any way I'm not saying
they shouldn't when they're doing their
traditional male jobs they have to note
they're producing testosterone and
they're not making enough female
hormones unless they have a personal
wash it stimulates more estrogen more
progesterone than their ancestors so we
have to change a whole new dynamic how
can women produce more estrogen
progesterone if most of the day they're
making testosterone and that's what my
message is is how can women come back to
their female size
men we have a challenge you know when I
was growing up growing up in the 50s I
saw my dad going to work every day I
don't know what he did but I knew that
one day I was going to have to make all
this money in order to support a family
and that was a pressure on me but I had
a role model who taught me I can do it
you can do it before I remember that
pressure oh my god I'm gonna have to do
that even watching him shave I remember
how do i how do I do that but when you
have a role model then you have
confidence confidence and men and women
increases testosterone so the
testosterone goes up then you have the
power and the energy to accomplish and
achieve but what motivates men is the
fire there has to be a fire to put out
there has to be a problem to solve it
has to be a person in need in order to
help them well it used to be that women
needed men so if a woman was dependent
on a man his testosterone will grow up
that's how my testosterone grew up if I
want to be successful in the world and
have a family and have a woman loved me
boy I need to get it together
so that's motivation men need motivation
to feel needed and if women don't need
men what I'm in for I don't need a man
so many women today they can't fall in
love because they don't feel they need a
man and they just their hormones are out
of balance because when testosterone
goes up you go I don't need anybody I
can do it myself
and if you feel that as a man you feel
quite good about yourself but almost
every woman for 40 years that I've been
counseling almost every woman when she's
unhappy one of the first things she says
as I explore her feelings and what's
going on and help her to express herself
is I do so much
there's no time I have to do it all
myself I'm all by myself my husband
ignores me he Ora is she single I just
have to do everything myself that is a
major source of stress for women because
when you feel I have to do it myself
that was gonna do it for me testosterone
goes up when they feel and this is
sociology teaches this now when you're
dependent on someone your estrogen goes
up that's the magic hormone for women
women actually have an orgasm their
estrogen levels have to double become 20
times higher than a man's estrogen
levels Shimon if I just tight notes at
this point George you have Frances full
and undivided attention that's what I do
my talks I see the men sort of wavering
on now women have an orgasm it is true
women to want sex see so many men
complain my wife doesn't want sex my
wife doesn't want sex now I know there's
many women listening and they're going
well my husband used to once sex he
doesn't want sex anymore and I'll tell
you why one of the reasons he doesn't
want sex anymore is because you're not
having the orgasms of happiness and joy
and you're remembering those moments
when you did have sex and you felt so
good and so when you say I want to have
sex and he doesn't actually what you
want is to feel those feelings that he
generates in you because for a woman
that double her estrogen levels it takes
a man okay our she's gay it takes a
skilled gay partner to take her to that
level of doubling her estrogen levels
but even with gay couples you know I
live in the Bay Area San Francisco gays
I have lots of fun I've had some clients
and so forth every comment what's very
common is a lack of polarity so let me
start with polarity creates attraction
opposites create attraction sameness
creates harmony so what you want to have
is relatedness harmony but also you have
to have differences that fit together
and when couples lose their attraction
often they've given up their authentic
self okay that's very important men have
stopped being masculine they're not
making enough testosterone because for a
man to be turned on is testosterone to
his wife his testosterone levels have to
go all the way up to normal and then
they have to double to fully last a long
time and sex
if this testosterone doesn't double he's
like the 1-minute guide okay but if he's
got testosterone doubles
he's like the 10-minute and of course
guy sometimes 20 minutes and of course
for fun you go for 10 hours
okay that's control
if you can do that but most men can't I
don't teach how to do that but you just
got double that testosterone is where
you fully feel surrender to her you are
no longer attached to ejaculate
okay because men go oh I want to come I
want to come and I don't want to come I
want to last longer oh but I want to
cover so what happens we lose control it
takes high testosterone in order to
maintain that but here's the rub the
more you love a woman your estrogen
levels go higher love is estrogen you
see for you to feel I need you that's
estrogen so it's a woman's fool
basically children well you got a skill
as a man to help bring your higher and
then when she goes higher she brings you
higher it's reciprocal so yeah we could
say it's her fault but she could say
it's our fault but John one of the
things I'm hearing kind of as a broad
thing behind everything you're saying is
it's it has become due to the changes in
the world it has become harder for men
to be happy and it has become harder for
women to be happy
is that fair saintly yeah that's a good
summary and this is kind of the
explanation why it's harder for couples
to be happier and why it's harder for
couples to stay attracted to each other
now the truth is now we go back to more
traditional relationships where the
culture said men should only do
testosterone things women should do
estrogen things those couples also ran
out of passion they ran out of passion
because they didn't have the higher
needs that I'm about to talk about okay
because when you want to maintain
passion like right now you see the
passion coming out of me because I'm
expressing my authentic self I'm
expressing both parts of me my masculine
side I'm skilled I'm disciplined I've
worked really hard to know what I know
I'm confident I'm making a difference
all those things pump up my testosterone
I also have complete trust and
relaxation and I'm happy and I also I
appreciate you guys and letting me talk
so that's my estrogen goes up I love
what I do
I do it well that means testosterone
goes up and estrogen goes up and that is
a higher need gets produced as the need
to self actualize and selfless service
to the world or it starts with selfless
service to your wife which is what you
get a glimpse of when you propose to her
what happens when you propose a woman
glows with ronsis pay attention at this
point man he's been putting it off for
years the most masculine thing at that
moment where a man proposes this is so
interesting what is the tradition the
men kneels before her see that's where
you honor the woman you're kneeling
you're selfless basically you're saying
I serve you and what is the greatest
moment in sex you know I used to teach
these just I still do seminars on sex
and what we did back back in that in the
early late 70s when I taught sex before
gender difference what happened then is
I just had a lot of sex but I used to
interview women before I have sex had a
lot of my this is going in a completely
different direction and I expected it to
carry on John okay he's nothing very
funny you're my joke on this I was a
month for nine years purely celibate and
then I started teaching classes on sex
and you go out of the month teach
classes on sex I was very I love sex I
was very active sexually as a teenager
then the Beatles got into meditation so
they're like my role model so I got into
meditation became a month very spiritual
I love it
I still meditate every day I love it
love it love it but during those days of
celibacy never never masturbated for
nine years in my 20s yeah you can do
that you can learn to do that yes yes
possible participate you got a big
erection doesn't mean you got to release
it celebrate it but you don't release
that energy then the energy goes up into
your brain you have these spiritual
experiences but then when I left being a
month
my brother was bipolar so I needed to
like study psychology meditation
didn't help him so I felt I can't be so
happy if my brother's suffering so
anyway so I left being a monk came out
in the world study psychology and then
of course if you haven't had sex in nine
years all you think about is sex so I
had one woman after another woman after
another one it was so much fun for me I
traveled around my little car spending
the night with women I'd read their palm
and then I'd say you know I've been a
month for nine years and I really need
to understand sex would you teach me so
because I was a monk I had permission to
ask and women would tell me all these
things and every woman not every woman
but almost every woman had a different
story women have different needs that
there's their mat and then don't
understand all the possibilities in
order to bring a woman higher because
men just grab it and he's done it right
hmm okay so now I'm like teaching these
classes on sex that led me to teaching
the Mars Venus ideas because you can't
maintain the passion unless you have the
differences but in the beginning of a
relationship you don't have to
understand differences to feel passion
what happens is the newness because
somebody is new and it's a challenge and
you don't know what's going to happen
what's it going to be like how are they
going to respond what will happen that
newness and uncertainty generates if
it's sexual generates massive amounts of
dopamine
that's pleasure dopamine motivation and
passion but then if you love a woman and
she loves you harmony starts to set in
and then you have predictability and you
have comfort you have ease relaxation
that lowers your dopamine so what keeps
your dopamine up is testosterone and
gender differences because if you're not
pumping up your testosterone and you're
more estrogen you won't be attracted to
your partner now here's they're also
very funny is because some men say yeah
I'm not turning on my wife but I have no
problem with sex I'm having it every day
online now I say yeah because we do have
sex online you're producing massive
amounts of dopamine and actually the sad
news is
all these teenagers masturbating to
internet porn all the time it's
addictive
which means it desensitizes the brain to
making more dopamine so what happens
then is you depend on the high dopamine
stimulation of fantasy and digital
stimulation and normal stimulation with
a woman that you care about it doesn't
produce enough dopamine so actually what
we're seeing I predicted it twenty years
ago as we came online with porn you're
gonna see men at 20 years old and this
is happening now
can't stay turned on to their partner
once they get to know her and some men
just if you talk to me I can't get
turned on don't speak that I could get
there done but to actually have real
relatedness caring sharing affection
that stimulates estrogen so if you're a
low testosterone guy and you love
someone you lose your attraction to them
so you have to maintain this gender
difference and we know biologically that
for women to be turned on to a man her
estrogen has to be 20 times higher than
his okay she has to shoot up with this
high level of estrogen and of the normal
estrogen levels of a man then he has to
double his testosterone to be or
multi-orgasmic with her to experience
fantastic falling in love orgasm which
is possible but it takes the interaction
of taking a person and this one's good I
love my message because we have to let
go the idea that our partner makes us
unhappy you know if we're in the
workplace and you're failing whose fault
is that there is you can't just keep
blaming the government and blaming other
people you're a loose
you will lose you won't succeed winners
if you achieve your goals is because
when things aren't working you go how
can I make it work what can I do and
when I teach classes on success
everybody goes yeah who's responsible
yeah
and then I said but then you get married
you come into counselors office who's
responsible finger always pointing the
finger and what that does what that does
is it takes away our ability to self
reflect and
change what we're doing but the truth is
it's like an automatic thing that we're
going to blame because we just don't
understand why is this not working it's
like what you said in the beginning
people just aren't happy
the attraction goes away what is
happening because they feel inside them
that I want this to happen it can happen
and of course we see it in the movies
but it's unrealistic to experience the
lifetime of passion unless we're able to
embrace both the masculine and feminine
sides of us and that's the good news
about all this gender neutrality is the
younger generation and the world due to
all the changes is allowing women to be
more masculine that pushes men into
becoming more feminine so we're waking
up to both our male and female size but
the problem is when women goes over the
mascot they get stuck over there
and that then causes a man to get stuck
over in his feminine side because what
are the symptoms of high estrogen and
men grumpy irritable passive angry
defensive argumentative and sometimes
our innate young cheese and all of us
would agree with that
[Laughter]
isn't it there's nothing wrong with
feeling love and emotions when they're
positive but what men start having
negative emotions then what happens is
you can measure in their body when they
have negative emotions cortisol is being
produced and drillin starts and then
cortisol gets produced their estrogen
levels are going higher their
testosterone is going low so this is
literally learning to balance everything
now is about balancing the masculine
with the feminine and you know there's
some really wonderful speakers out there
and I'm thinking of one and she says you
know women we're always trying to
balance our life women hear about all
the time trying to balance just let go
of it you can't balance it just go with
the flow don't you just can't find it
and I go yes you can find balance if you
know the opposite of what you're doing
is actually something that will work for
you but it doesn't feel natural you see
if I go off sugar or high desserts or
ice cream ice cream just makes me fat
but I love it so I don't need it unless
I get really skinny then ohh
and one day I can gain 10 pounds
eating's of ice cream and this is my
physiology the boy does it feel right it
feels so good the things that are wrong
for us often feels so good and that's
where we get it doesn't feel so natural
to eat ice cream just give me my ice
cream it feels so good drug addicts Oh
drink it so much this is so natural but
then it throws you out of balance so
generally the things that put you out of
balance feel natural and the things that
will put you in balance you resist and
you know that's not me I don't feel it I
don't want to do it so I tell women one
of the best ways to produce estrogen is
to feel loved
well I can't feel bad I'm mad at him
okay then what you have to do is feel
your emotions if you feel your emotions
you begin to feel again and then as you
feel through your emotions you come back
to feeling your love again but it takes
time for women women process stress and
being out of balance by building up
their estrogen and what does it is
talking about what you feel basically
becoming naked if a woman you know if a
woman becomes naked a man gets turned on
with the reality if a man's a good
listener and create safety for a woman
she wants to get naked otherwise you
don't want to get naked
well sharing your emotions is a higher
level of nakedness it's revealing what's
inside of me but often what's inside of
her at the surface is anger at him he's
not going to hear that either put your
clothes back on turned out the lights
here I don't want to see that okay so
she's got to process her emotions to
increase estrogen which is authenticity
of what's inside has to come out and be
accepted be understood be felt someone
has to empathize so women have to learn
to get in touch with their feelings and
share it with somebody who relates to it
instead of gets defensive
women will complain all the time my
husband can't hear me my husband can't
hear me they come to me for counseling
after a while they feel so good they
just because I can listen and whatever
and empathize and they come back again
again after about six sessions they say
why is it that you are such a good
listener and my husband doesn't and
can't I say three reasons one all your
complaints are not about me if your
complaints were about me
I would be defensive yeah anytime you've
complained to a man his testosterone
goes down his estrogen goes up he wants
to get on fight-or-flight so first of
all your complaints are not about me
second you pay me what payment do you
give your husband and by the way what is
the payment that men need at home
your love your acceptance your
appreciation and also taking off your
clothes okay all those things is like I
scored us this big time then so I get
paid you're not complaining about me and
also I know there's a time limit that's
the most important one you saved it for
last yeah we can learn these things make
it back to here anything if you start
out maybe even have a complaint about
him that's hard for men to listen learn
in the beginning so but you have to
always come from a place of love if
you're not coming from a place of love
nobody's going to hear you that's it and
as a man you can't hear a woman unless
you're coming from a place of love and
certainly you shouldn't be talking
because when men talk when they're not
coming from a place of hormonal balance
and their heart is open the same thing
how harmonious means your heart is open
if you're talking when you're angry
biologically what happens men your
estrogen goes up stop talking and if
you're a good listener listening it's
actually the most masculine thing you
can do now let me just point that out
when you listen you're penetrating into
her that's what sex is very masculine
thing erection when you are when you
learn wow if I could just listen and not
talk I'm gonna get an erection I'm gonna
give her an orgasm because when you
penetrate that's very masculine and so
what he's doing by being a good listener
he's building his testosterone which
allows her to go to her estrogen side
and testosterone always wants to create
safety always once did serve and
eventually when it goes really high it
becomes totally no-self now see as a
yogi our meditator for me the highest
state are not the highest but one of the
higher states you get to is there's no
self first you think you know the self
which is
a soul which is eternal okay well that's
the self then who's this guy with this
body
who's this mind that's a no self that's
not me that's just the programming and
who was behind here is the soul that
lives on and on and on
this is just one life for that that's
what you learn when you experience those
things when you meditate 50 years okay
so you know teach meditation but there's
basic levels and I'll just toss in here
for all the people who tried meditation
because it's so popular now it's so
popular now people try it and then they
go I'm so bored I'm so bored I'm just
I'm just sitting there trying to have no
thoughts I'm so bored I'm just looking
at my breathing and it's so boring well
guess what for most people they're too
advanced to do that let me just say that
again
they're too advanced that do the common
meditation techniques see we've gotten
to a higher level when you can both be
on your masculine feminine sides you
have to bring them into balance
meditation the old techniques of
meditation are particularly designed
simply to calm the primitive brain when
you notice your breathing are you
practice breathing then what you're
doing is connecting the front part of
your brain to the instinctive part of
your brain which does things things
automatically but that's just the
beginning and so let's say you're in
first grade or your little kid and
you're learning mathematics one plus one
is two one plus one is two Apple AP ple
you do that is very exciting it's all
new it's challenging but then it become
boring after a while you got to go to
the next level you know you gotta get
the hell Gibran you know you get to the
higher levels even for some people get
the calculus you go amazing problem I
can solve this you know the higher
levels if you're not getting if you're
not challenged you'll become bored so we
have to really upgrade our meditation
skills we have to upgrade our
relationship skills because we're in a
new world now so what do women need us
for cuz remember women if you don't need
a man you're not gonna be turned on to
him you gotta feel and of course all
these sensitive guys were always
worrying about what you think and feel
and then what you say what do you think
and feel then we talked about our
feelings
and then she gets turned off to us if we
think
doing what everybody says you should do
I'm not against men talking about their
positive feelings and I'm not against
men sharing their feelings it may be
frustration and disappointment concerns
but only after a woman comes back to
feeling her heart is open otherwise when
men get to estrogen oriented women start
feeling like your mother and then they
resent being your mother because you're
supposed to be my husband and do you
find that what we are now experiencing
John because of the culture that we have
in particular the culture wars is
actually men being told that somehow
masculinity is wrong it's wrong to be a
man is wrong to embrace additional male
values which then makes men unhappy
which then impacts on relationships
absolutely and what gets reinforced
because we don't have love for men as a
culture embracing understanding and
appreciating men and let me say that is
a reaction from femininity because men
have not embraced femininity women have
been on a downslide for a long time in
the past where you know if she was a
homemaker and she raised her children
men did not respect that is suddenly
when men started making money for what
they do
then suddenly if I make more money I'm
better man than you okay that's the main
goal in the hierarchy and then suddenly
we look put that on the woman so she's
at home with her children this is back
in those days and she's like needing to
share because she feels ignored and
neglected because he's working all the
time to make more money and then she
gets upset he says well you don't do
anything I do the big stuff I'm more
important than you who are you to
complain why aren't you happy you have
more things than other women you should
be happy that's why you get rich people
are so so unhappy because the man often
thinks not always but often thinks you
have no right to be unhappy you have no
right to complain about things because
look out of your life we have so much
more what's wrong with you and what men
men don't understand how putting down
how disrespectful that is to hurt so
women have lost respect over after a
while the whole thing went downhill
wants men start making money
then cuz money said you have more value
more value women lost respect then women
said I want respect because they need
respects of men are getting respect for
making money then I'm going to go make
money that elevated the whole
consciousness to where women are saying
I can be masculine just like you but the
problem that goes with that is oh I
forgot how to be feminine how I have
both at the same time is our new
challenge today and one of the benefits
of that is self-actualization which
means well one of the big benefits of it
is you don't get divorced you can have
an intact family you know you mentioned
that you know we've made men wrong well
also what what happens besides making
men wrong is little boys grow up what's
it like to be a man and their fathers
are gone because when you make men wrong
you have more divorce when you have more
divorce you have boys growing up without
fathers in most cases the majority not
because the father doesn't want to take
care of the child sometimes that's the
case but the pajama jority of it in our
court system today there's a bias the
mother always gets the young child
teenager it's discussed but the young
child the mother gets the child there's
a bias as opposed to what I think it
should be is equal time and embracing
both sides and for parents to know that
if you're unhappy with your partner
you're hurting your children your
whether you're divorced or single if
you're unhappy with your problem what a
boy learns if a father says bad things
about the mother then he learns Oh women
are not worthy of my respect in my love
so I don't care if a little girl or a
boy grows up and the mother bad mouse
the father which the research showed
women do six times more than men and
that's because they need to express how
they feel more in the time than men but
when she expresses that complaints about
her husband negative feelings what is a
boy gonna hear well if I'm like my dad
I'm a bad person I should be more like
my mom and there's a lot of qualities of
masculinity that often get judged as
dysfunction and they're not for example
simple ideas many
cave time he needs to be close then he
needs to pull away men don't like it
when you tell him what to do and women
say what he needs to know what to do I
need to tell him what to do I said no
you don't you complain you want to
change him that doesn't work you can't
do that if you want amazing sex and a
great relationship and long time well
how do I get more if I want more you
learn how to open your heart give him
what he needs then ask for more in small
increments just like you would do it a
business you wouldn't ask for massive
raise you wouldn't say I cuz I heard if
you don't double my salary you'd ask for
increments okay it's a gradual process
everything is gradual but women don't
understand the psychology of men men
don't understand the psychology of women
it's you know in the beginning of a
relationship what happens is men
naturally do the things that win a woman
over and what are those natural things
we do in the beginning listen to a
little stuff little stuff you hold her
hand
we stroked her hair we tell her how
pretty she is we call her you know we
think about her all these little things
actually stimulate estrogen then we get
married and then we do the big thing I
go to work I support my family I'm a
Ricard and we think because I do that I
don't need to do the little things but
what we don't understand is men is that
for estrogens if you're an estrogen
being little things are just as
important as big things so it's not how
big it is it's how many little things
you do along with occasional big things
big things are nice without a doubt it's
special as glorious that's basically on
my anniversary on my wife's birthday
there's holidays you give a lot of extra
attention to a woman she feels so
special but what keeps her feeling loved
is lots of little things that you did in
the beginning and every man can do it if
you've got a wife you figured it out you
just didn't know you figured it out
because you weren't doing yet the big
stuff so the logic and of course women
think about how you were in the
beginning of the relationship when he
did little things you were so
appreciative of it but after a while he
does romantic gestures and because
you're maybe doing his laundry or
picking up after
and then he takes you out the dinner to
go where he should take me out to dinner
I do his laundry
you know women start to take men for
granted men start to take women for
granted particularly because we don't
understand our vulnerabilities our
sensitivities and our basic hormonal
needs and to summarize hormonal needs
and this is I love this you know
admitted from Mars I wrote what men need
most is to feel appreciated to feel
accepted not trying to change them and
trust it that they're doing their best
and they're there for you okay
and one of the things women do wrong all
the time as soon as the man's late she
goes oh I can't trust him I can't trust
as soon as a man makes mistakes oh you
should change you did that we remind she
reminds us of what we do and tries to
change what we do and you're [ __ ] up
and then he does stuff for her and she
goes yeah but I do more stuff for you so
he doesn't feel appreciated appreciation
acceptance and Trust are the major
testosterone producers and what's ironic
is that women are always think I don't
feel appreciated well when you say I
don't feel appreciated how do you think
he feels he feels like boy if I really
failed he needs the vitamin appreciation
more than her she needs it but he needs
it more and I promise you if you
appreciate a man a lot he will really
appreciate you more that's the key feed
him what he needs and it brings forth
his best self and naturally he will
begin to do the things that feed her now
one of the things that feed estrogen
this is a really amazing thing is that
when you demonstrate I care I'm
considered of your needs of your wishes
I care about you caring and this is a
little foreign to many men a real
experience of caring is if you've got a
new car and somebody did the side of it
when you park it you come back and your
reaction is oh my car that's feeling the
pain of something that's what caring is
one part of caring and wanting to
protect willing to carry I remember my
wife we bought these expensive plates
and I would take it around the
dishwasher and she said no no
this is how you hold the plates like a
little baby okay that's caring you know
I didn't learn so much about caring
because when I grew up there were six
boys in my family and I remember
visiting my mother and you don't have to
I made some money whatever I went back
home I said mom you still have these
green plastic plates from childhood you
should get some nice place I'll buy you
a nice place she said oh no I don't need
it I said why did you have such cheap
plates
she said when you've got six boys
they're gonna drop those plates you need
plastic plates look so they basically if
you want if you want the sensitivities
of a woman to come out you have to
demonstrate caring it's expensive China
it's called cherishing sensitivity
consideration so every act of caring is
going to produce estrogen every act of
understanding that's why women would
complain in the 90s I did this from
listening to women's complaints what are
they really missing they feel he doesn't
care about me he doesn't listen to me
women need to be seen and heard and
understood that's such an important
thing if I can share how I feel inside
then my estrogen goes up that's talking
about your feelings and having somebody
empathize with you that's why men you
already have too much estrogen don't
talk about your feelings to a woman talk
to guys about a lot of laugh at you yeah
get over a big deal make fun of it and
its really a big loss feel empathy of
certainly there's times when it's a big
problem then it's appropriate but for
little problems you know your wife said
this you do this you share what happened
and then you share accountability how
did I how did I miss what did I do wrong
what was a foolish thing I did be light
about it may need to lighten up women
need to go deep then they lighten up
when men can be light about it then they
can go deeper so limit what the third
one women need trust I mean women need
his caring women need understanding and
here's the big one that I talked about
in early this is why there's so many
problems from our history that we're
trying to fix is women need respect you
know when you when you look at all the
books even the Christian books which
talk about love they always say you
respect the man the man needs respect
yeah
if you agree with the man if you serve
the man he'll he'll be great but he'll
be selfish selflessness is masculinity
so when men learn to respect women and
treat them as equals and even more than
equals sometimes that's respecting
that's a steaming that's an honoring so
what does a man do when he proposes to a
woman we're back to that one he kneels
process pay attention bullying now
that's what John John approved of it he
said that I didn't make fun of you
that's what each other don't do it
around women though they think oh you're
being so mean to each other you're so
hurtful that's the first thing my wife
taught me I hate your sense of humor and
I felt like around you and she says no
and she got out of the car and walked
away no no no okay okay but inside I
felt like what I can't be I can't be
myself around you then I realized we all
have parts of ourselves that are
appropriate to share with our partners
hmm parts of ourselves that are not
appropriate I put in male friends I can
be as funny as I want I can be as light
as I want I can be as cynical as I want
it's just they understand instinctively
because I lighten up things that way
whereas women you can't do that with him
when they're upset and that's one of our
big mistakes again he's talking we want
to we want to laugh at her oh that's a
no big deal what do you why are you
feeling that way that's silly that's
ridicul come on are you kidding that's a
big deal dude the sensitivities they
have are different and some women have
toughened up you know and their husbands
are more sensitive what that means is
they're out of balance she needs to come
back he needs to come back toughen up
and then he can be on his female side
you know I'm not like all like men
should be stoic and never have feelings
is when a woman is expressing her
feelings if you can not get defensive if
you can't not take it personally which
means if she's upset today
that means she's saying I failed her
even if she says I failed her it doesn't
mean I failed her inside I know it's her
job to be happy but if I listen to her
I'm helping her to be happy
and then she can remember all the good
things I do and she'll be happier it's
our job to be happy and then if we can
find our happiness
certainly as partners we cannot make it
worse and that's a problem men
unknowingly make it worse we don't
realize women of these different beings
and they require a different kind of
support and that's that's the lack of
respect for women respect stimulates
estrogen respect creates safety and that
that's why this understanding that came
around 15 years ago oxytocin is a
hormone of touch when you when a woman
gets dressed up and you go oh you look
so beautiful tonight
right away oxytocin gets produced if you
hold her hand just for 10 seconds not
the whole evening you know it's like a
little boy walking across the street
just ten seconds put your arm around her
just ten seconds you don't have to do it
you know your arm gets really tired how
long do I have to do this I don't want
it to feel rejected when I go away
that's oxytocin too much oxytocin and
then actually lowers your testosterone
that's why men don't instinctively
cuddle after having sex after sex we
have a huge release of oxytocin which
lowers our testosterone which causes us
to pull away so naturally you want to
pull away and why do you want to pull
away because pulling away separateness
creates testosterone connection creates
estrogen and yes I loved a sturgeon
estrogen is pleasure
it's enjoyment it's love it's surrender
but testosterone is also important to
feel confident okay to feel free to feel
connected to who my power inside and
that's what you want is stamina in the
bedroom as well if you have that you
bring a woman to higher levels of
estrogen don't you know it happens when
men learn how to be selfless
selflessness and so it's ironic when I
go to meditate I'm taking care of myself
but then as I fill up with testosterone
there
I now truly want to come back and be
more selfless and you'll see this dance
women have to recognize this is the
dance of men they want to get close and
then they pull away when you're wanting
to get close you feel I can't live
without you and then you get enough of
her your estrogen goes up your
testosterone goes down now you got to
pull away and go you know I can't live
without you now I need to be on my own
for a while and women go are you crazy
are you schizophrenic one day you're so
loving the next day you're ignoring me
no this is a normal dance when men get
really close they naturally pull away
they will come back but they never come
back if a man pulls away and a woman
runs after him yeah how do women right
after men they they want to change you
they come back or come back
what did I do wrong or that's where they
get all they respect him rather than
appreciate him they go I'll do more
things for you I'll take care of you oh
I understand your problems that all just
increases his estrogen or one of the
things they do to go after you as ask
what your feelings let's connect let's
tell me what you feel what did I do
wrong all those things actually push him
in a way yet she thinks she's pulling
him back another thing women do is when
men go to their cave they feel better
they come out of the cave and then she
gives him a look that's like slapping
his hand you ignored me you hurt me you
didn't call back you're a bad person
and so that's a stress so what a men do
to handle stress we go back into the
cave and eventually we go into the cave
and we want to come out we go oh if I
come out I'm just gonna be punished so
go back into the cave it's our safe zone
because women don't appreciate that men
go to their cave
I remember the change in my marriage of
34 years when my wife she said to me I
don't know maybe six years into the
marriage I went to my cave after we're
getting an argument I just said look let
me just take some time to think about
this my heart's closed and and instead
of going why'd your heart closed why are
you listening to me tell me how you feel
she just let me go
and when I came back after opening my
heart again I came back I was
affectionate to her we didn't have the
same conversation again you give it time
to warm up again and I came back and she
said John I just want to thank you for
going to your cave
because I didn't get I didn't have to
experience your Dragon I feel you coming
back with love and then after about 23
years into the marriage I said to her
how do i how do you rate me as a husband
you know I wanted him she said as a
father to our children you're the
unbelief you're a plus you're the very
best father I can imagine as a husband
you're certainly not perfect but John I
don't that's a perfect moment to then
move on to the final part of the of the
episode ease which we're going to be
talking about and we'll do it very very
briefly because we're coming towards the
end timewise but and it's been brilliant
we're faced and couples in particular
faced with a unique set of challenges
with the lockdown situation with the
coronavirus whereby wait you know we're
including closed spaces how do we keep
our marriages and our love together in
these very very challenging times if
we're a part where if we're together and
I can do it briefly because I've given
the foundation for it it's just an
excerpt of what I've just said and it's
that last point she says you're not a
perfect husband but you've given me the
greatest gift a woman could want I said
what's that that was like my redeeming
moment and she said whenever you're
angry or upset with me and I know I can
make you angry and upset you stop
talking you go to your cave and you
always come back with more love so I
know there's nothing I can say or do it
will push you out of my life security
that's the most important thing to women
to feel safe that when they're not
loving if they're selfish if they're
angry if they're complaining that
they're not going to lose you that
you'll still love them and with this
understanding helps men to do that which
is but you can't once your buttons get
pushed you get angry upset you pull away
so now coronavirus we're all isolated
quarantined into our house we're there
it's too much connection when connection
too much connection happens men's
testosterone goes down they start
getting irritable they get cabin fever
they get grumpy they're there and then
when he's grumpy that makes her feel not
safe and while she's what she's not
feeling safe then her emotions her
here starts putting her in a stress
reaction when women go in just stress
reaction there's a bias towards seeing
everything that's wrong you see life is
always every man has problems but good
qualities what allows women to keep
their heart open is not focusing on the
negative but seeing the positive along
with the negative it's okay it's no big
deal that's a million-dollar phrase if a
woman wants to ask a man of something
don't complain just say honey you know
sometimes like my wife
I learned this with her when she said
you know she was so frustrated because
for years I would leave the lights on
the living room when I walked through
because I needed to light on to go
through and then she would follow later
and have to turn off the lights and
that's a big deal to her not such a big
deal to me so I don't think about it I
even have free free solar she'd say
we're wasting energy you know the
environment we have to protect the
environment say we're using solar energy
she says still we have to set an example
and leave those so I have to honor that
respect that this is her value system so
I honor that but still inside it's not
so contrary to me because I solved the
problem by having solar energy so anyway
the lights would stay on I kept
forgetting kept forgetting she's so
frustrated and one day she figured this
out she said John what she did wrong
she'd always say you forgot the light
again am I supposed to just follow you
around and turn out lights she shamed me
she disapprove of me she complained to
me that's a stress message and helps me
to forget it whenever you push a man
down he will forget him push away you
can't help bring out the best of him if
you're complaining so what she said is
John I know sometimes most of the time
you turn the light out but sometimes you
forget and then I have to run around
turning out lights would you try to
remember I'd really appreciate it
no big deal see that tone of voice
everything is tone of voice but words
can help it's not a big deal but I
really appreciate you turn out the
lights the tone of voice says it even
with the phrase it's not a big deal
helps a man to relax his heart can open
you can hear but as soon as you go oh
I'm so upset with you you didn't do this
you didn't do this that means women your
heart is closed you're out of balance
you're trying to change him you're on
your
male side negative emotions happen on
your male side so come back to your
female side share those negative
emotions write a minute journal share
them as irrational as trash to throw
away share with somebody who empathize
with you call up a girlfriend talking
about what you're feeling and learn to
do it in 10 minutes don't go on and on
and if you don't interrupt you can do it
in 10 minutes become efficient and sort
of processing negativity and you talk to
somebody but not your partner now it's
really hard for women and at these times
when they're together because here's an
example when when I used to write at
home okay when I'm sitting in front of
the computer my wife would always feel
ignored by me but if I'm writing in my
office she goes oh he's at the office
she didn't take it personally women tend
to take it personally you're sitting
there watching TV and she's feeling he's
not looking at me he's ignoring me she
might want to come up and talk to you
and you go away I'm watching the show
it's an important moment TVs more
important than me you know so women take
these things personally because they
need more estrogen so it's appropriate
so you've got to build up her estrogen
during this time because when her
estrogen is opened then she's not needy
okay I'm needy of your affection and
attention which means it's I need more
than I should need it's like I need I'm
empty I build me up and of course that
makes him feel like he's failed his
testosterone goes down so when he's
thinking his face and men have to learn
to take your space and feel okay about
it she sees him do that she's gonna be
upset about even with this knowledge
it's gonna be hard for her because she
doesn't have enough estrogen so what
happened she feels needy for that
attention so here's a fun thing you can
do this will really spice up your sex
life as well every other day you play a
game and this is the game which you can
continue doing because I play this game
and I love it for the when the Sun sets
after the Sun sets you play the game of
Jeannie you become her genie and so
everything she wants is as you wish as
you wish
she watched The Princess Bride the movie
the guy who wins the woman's heart the
princess he wins her heart by always
saying as you wish as you wish is my
pleasure to make you happy it is my
pleasure to do your bidding it is my
pleasure I will do this for you
so you're the genie you become her
servant and she becomes the master she's
the master of the servant she you are
the genie whatever you wish is within my
power but it's not like I wish you would
clean up the yard tomorrow that's not in
the game the game is like in the next
three hours before we go to bed whatever
I want you to do right now I will ask
you to do it and I will oversee it I
will see you doing it for me it's not
like I want you to go go to the store
and buy something that's something in
the house although blowing the store is
not a long time away it's okay she needs
to see you doing her bidding but she has
to ask she can't just you can't be this
perfect husband who says oh you need my
help I'll anticipate it no you have to
ask so you can practice knowing it's a
safe zone for this three hours he will
do whenever you wish without a grumble
without a growl I'll be happy to do it
he always says I'm happy to do it
your wish is my command I love doing
this for you it would be so much fun
it's only three hours if you can't do
three hours men do two hours say your
parameters don't do it every day do it
every other day but when that happens
what happens when she feels she's your
master okay she has the power to get you
to do something that strengthens her
masculine confidence which allows her to
feel now I'm safe to go to my female
side and ask as most women don't ask
they will they what they do is they
expect you should do this you should do
this so no shoulds just saying honey
would you do this not even could you do
this as a subtlety there could you do
only if you can would you do this it's
the wood just honey would you do this
would you do this would you move the
chair for me would you give me a glass
of tea would you watch the dishes
tonight would you take care of the kids
for the next 20 minutes give him
specific tasks to do for you
you that would make you feel more
relaxed and appreciate and practice
smiling and enjoying it it's like you're
like the ideal husband I love you I want
that genie you're amazing give her a
chance to feel in control because when
women don't feel on the feminine side
that they have power they go to their
masculine side where they have to do
everything themselves to practice
letting him do for you and men you will
gain so much from this because the most
masculine thing you can do is to
selflessly serve no grumbles no Noi ins
but you've got the power you can make
her happy so this is like the fun game
the genie game she's the master and
you're the genie you provide as you wish
so amazing and look it's been a great
interview thank you so much for your
time we really appreciate as I said some
of your advice has been useful to me and
my wife in our life and I'm sure many
other people watching as well and it's
also been very useful to me because I
found out everywhere I'm going wrong so
thank you for that absolutely I really
particularly enjoyed when you spend an
hour talking about the importance of
listening and then Francis interrupted
you mid-story I really enjoyed that
but anyway John the last question we
always ask our guests is what is the one
thing very briefly that we're not
talking about that we ought to be
talking about you mean while we're in
the in the cove in anything at all
anything at all more broadly at any
point as a society what is the one thing
that we're not talking about that we
ought to be talking about sex we're not
talking enough about sex no we're not
talking about sex we should talk about
what I like what I don't like what you
like what you don't like when you want
to have it initiating sex people just
don't feel comfortable talking about sex
we need to understand women the big
thing in my sex classes which was a
revelation for women that the number one
thing men want and sex is for her to be
happy and women think oh I can't ask for
what I want and he just thinks about
himself and to understand why you know
men are so fast because we're Ferraris
what we have to do is slow down women
are so slow and that their norm does
turn out
think it takes time to build up the
estrogen but if you take the time your
testosterone will go higher as well but
if you go really fast it's too much
energy and you release too quickly so if
you slow down for the woman she will
speed up and want you more than you want
her and that is power men that sounds
very much like power thank you so much
for coming on chicken homage to John we
really appreciate it thank you for
watching and listening and we'll see you
tomorrow on the live stream see you
tomorrow guys bye-bye thanks for
watching guys as always subscribe to the
YouTube channel click the bell button
next to subscribe button so you get
notified when a video comes out and
follow us on all the social media at
trigger pod and also leave us a nice
review on iTunes and spread the word